welcome to Horry sabe de channel where
we discussed the latest tech news and
delve into newest tech products today
we're taking a look at ddr5 RAM and
where it is and should you wait for it
but before we delve into that make sure
to hit that subscribe button if you guys
like to stay updated with the latest
techniques related gaming and pcs so
let's start off by covering the rumors
that we have so far the biggest rumor by
far that we have so far is that ddr5 Ram
will be twice the speed of ddr4 Ram
jtech claims that they have already
started working on the ddr 5 standard
and that it'll support
double the bandwidth and density of ddr4
Ram and that is supposed to allow it to
have greater power efficiency as well it
is also rumored that ddr5 DIMMs will
have double the capacity of ddr4 games
so we may see that DDR 5:16 you might
Stix will become more popular than what
DDR 460 new white kids are right now and
the go to configuration may be 32
gigabytes of ddr4 Ram but ddr5 Ram is
going to be more expensive and the RAM
situation right now is already bad so we
probably won't see that become popular
for a couple of years - and the last
rumor is that ddr5 Ram will come out at
the end of 2018 however unfortunately
that rumor is a little bit misleading
ddr5 Ram may be standardized at the end
of this year but you won't be able to
get hands on until 2019 or 2020 ddr4 Ram
is still in its mid cycle really it only
hit the mainstream platform four years
ago and if you look behind that ddr3 RAM
came all the way out in 2007 so I was a
seven year lifecycle and before that
ddr2 RAM came out because in three so
that had a four eight lifecycle and the
original DDR Ram came out in 2000 which
means that had a three year life cycle
so as you guys can see the life cycles
have been progressively getting bigger
place technology is an advancing ask
quickly that doesn't necessarily mean
that the ddr4 Ram life cycle will be
more than seven years but there
definitely is no rush to implement ddr5
for any manufacturers and so it
definitely will take some time
the main issue with this is that it
takes a while for new Rams to enter
to be widely implemented for example it
took two years after ddr4 Ram came out
for it to be widely implemented into
computers this is because new RAM
iterations are generally not forwards or
backwards compatible and as results we
have to wait for AMD and Intel to make
new chipsets that support the new
standard of RAM AMD usually comes out
with the new chipsets in March with
their rise in series and during the
summer with thread Ripper series and
Intel usually comes out with the new
chipsets at the end of the year in the
fall with their main stream platform or
contain the summer with their enthusiast
line so the earliest implementation of
DDR 5 Ram that we may see is in the
March of 2019 and that's only for rising
really and intel's mainstream platform
won't support ddr5 ramp probably until
the end of next year
and as a result ddr5 ram will become
popular until 2020 even if it is
standardized at the end of this year for
example it's been four years since ddr4
Ram came out but most Mac still use
lpddr3 Ram as a result it's definitely
gonna take time and many manufacturers
may be a bit reluctant to implement the
new standard for a variety of reasons
overall ddr5 Ram may be released at the
end of this year but you won't even be
able to use it until at least a March of
2019 and on top of that or the pioneer
of this new DDR fly Ram and as a result
you're going to have to face all the
bugs and issues that come along with new
technology also for real-world
performance make sure to keep in mind it
is an octet it really improve your
experience that budget windows and most
apps are still going to be identical and
in games you may get 10 to 20 more fps
and the main place at DDR fire Ram will
shine is RAM hungry apps like Premiere
Pro and After Effects but for the vast
majority of people it really won't make
that much of difference so should you
wait well honestly it's quite a long
wait and I think the only reason you
wouldn't just go ahead and buy ddr4 Ram
right now is if you really don't need an
upgrade
also I highly doubt that DDR fire Ram
will be supported by current generation
motherboards or any other motherboards
I'll come out this year as a result if
you just recently built a PC or are
planning to build a PC with Rison 2 or
the later cannon lake or ice lake or
whatever is coming out from Intel later
this year well then you're out of luck
because it won't really support DDR fire
ramp and so there's no point in you guys
waiting if you're building a rising
system then I guess it is possible
because rising is much more backwards
compatible so technically you can buy a
next-generation motherboard from next
year and still use it with the rise in
CP whether you have right now and then
also upgrading ddr5 Ram but I really
don't think that's worth the hassle ask
for Intel you can't even do that
probably so that's out of the question
the extra speed that DDR my ram will
provide is simply not worth all the
hassle and extra money that would
require to just upgrade your motherboard
Verizon and there's also no point in
wasting perfectly good hardware
so the only reason you would consider
waiting for ddr5 Ram is if you have a
computer right now that is at its end of
its lifecycle and you're planning on
upgrading it very soon but even then it
may not be worth waiting for ddr5 ramp
considering how much time there still is
so here's the gist of it don't wait for
ddr5 RAM unless you are planning on
building computer in the imminent future
it's really as simple as that current
generation of motherboards simply won't
support it and it doesn't make sense to
just replace your motherboard for ddr5
Ram so unless you're planning on
building a computer next year then just
don't wait for it so overall ddr5 Ram is
going to be much faster than ddr4 Ram
and provide great performance but for
the vast majority of people there's no
point in waiting because of how long
there still is before it'll be a
clementa in the mainstream platform so
how do you guys feel about ddr5 ram do
you think that it'll be super fast or do
you think that it won't make that much
of difference make sure to comment down
below because I do read all my comments
and I'm curious as to what you guys
think so make sure to post your thoughts
also if you guys like this video then
and make sure drop a like and hit that
subscribe button if you guys like to see
more videos just like this every single
day but until next time bye